season 11 episode 21 mcdreamy says good
night let's watch it together
[Music]
okay first mistake he's making here you
need to call for help
my phone's not working because there's
very limited things you can do on the
road without any tools you need to call
for help and get emergency transport to
get them to a hospital where they could
actually be taken care of hey i can't
open the door
ma'am hey
hey what's your name sarah sarah who's
winnie my daughter
hey
you winnie
i think i'm dead
well you're not dead i can feel a pulse
in your wrist and you can't be dead if
your heart's still beating i see i'm a
doctor and i'm telling you
everyone know you're dead feel your
pulse
maybe that's a little dark thing to say
to a child listen getting you out it's
gonna hurt a lot i don't know if it's
shock or if it's that my leg hurts so
badly that i almost can't recognize it
almost feels normal so maybe um it will
be so bad getting me out sounds like
you're just looking at your head how
does he know that he's just like
feeling around over there and he's like
yeah dislocated there
yeah no special test eh i gotta get you
out of this car
down on the ground
and then pop it back in the socket how
does he know it's dislocated versus like
a full-on fracture that's displaced he
just has miraculous hands that have
x-ray field
the dislocation is cut off the blood
supply to your leg if i don't do
something you could lose it so that's
the only time you would do a reduction
in the field like this if you see that
the vascular supply meaning the blood
flow that is going to the lower limb is
obstructed because of the uh dislocation
that can happen in this case yeah he
should try and put it back so that he
restores blood flow otherwise literally
the rest of her leg starts dying into
crossing
whenever you do a reduction of
dislocation initially worst pain ever
afterwards feels kind of good
oh
does it hurt anymore
i'm not supposed to be here i have to go
excited you're probably in shock okay
you have a lot of adrenaline going
through you right now there might be
something wrong with you that you don't
feel right now so i need you to slow
down that is very accurate in fact
paramedics are trained to
tell folks who've been in car accidents
to calm down because it's very easy to
say i'm fine i'm fine i don't need to go
get emergency care because you are on
adrenaline you don't feel your internal
injuries and you could potentially be
bleeding out and it's also so important
to know the mechanism of the injury like
the fact that this was such a high steep
car accident already puts her at a high
risk of severe fractures vertebral
fractures internal bleeding
i just need to undo a button so i can
look at your stomach he's going to see
like bruising
or he's going to see a giant laceration
with intestines gotta hand it to you doc
go and have yourself a drink you earned
it
oh
and that's why you don't stop in the
middle of the road
blunt force trauma to the head chest and
abdomen persistent hypotension after two
liters of saline post is ready at 1 30.
okay so that's important information so
after giving him two liters of fluids to
try and bump up his blood pressure it's
still persistently low which means that
he's in a dangerous spot ideally they
want to give him more fluids more blood
products if that fails you have to start
him on pressers in order to keep his
blood pressure up to give sufficient
blood flow to the vital organs also they
said his blood uh his pulse is 130 which
means that it's fast tachycardic reason
being is when the blood pressure is low
the heart tries to compensate by beating
faster in order to like fake increase
the pressure can you hear me
yes yes i can hear
you loss of verbal skills possible
bleeding in the brain peoples are equal
and reactive good sign still should get
a ct got a flail chest in the right i
need a 36 french tube now uh so they
said he has a flail chest that means he
has significant rib fractures like
complete fractures on one side maybe
even a pneumothorax because what happens
is when you have a complete disconnect
of your chest like that your breathing
happens paradoxically um on the side
where you have your injury this is gonna
hurt but we have to do it
they're basically putting in a chest
tube to drain it uh his chest of blood
because he's bleeding internally which
will allow his lungs and potentially his
heart to expand uh when they are beating
and filling up with either air or blood
respectively you also sometimes if you
have a pneumothorax a collapsed lung
when you equalize the pressure you allow
the lung to expand as well he fixed her
leg he helped charlie
and he put a lot of insides back and he
saved us he saved you all of us
he's a doctor
he's a doctor so you should treat him
differently than you would any other
patient
what we've got you it is all gonna be
okay
this isn't right
[Music]
you should have taken me to get a head
ct
any time you have blunt force trauma to
the head with a serious accident again
mechanism of injury semi truck hitting
you at a fast rate of speed get cts we
over order cts in emergency rooms for
things that don't really matter yet when
people have a really high-speed car
accident people like should we get a
head tt yes you need to figure out if
there's bleeding internally because your
management completely changes we have to
work fast people i'm stable guys i'm
stable take me to get the head ct the
way you decide if stable is you look at
their vitals if his blood pressure is
not tanking you know that the patient is
stable enough to go get a head ct and if
there's bleeding in the brain you want
to save the brain because without the
brain there is no body uh he's got a
great deal in the back meredith would
leave it let's leave it check the four
quadrants and she double check the retro
hepatic space the retro hepatic space is
a very commonly known one that you learn
in uh your surgery rotations where you
can lose a lot of blood and not even
know it he's still hypotensive hylum is
intact he's not bleeding in his chest
this makes no sense we're missing
something for t-e-e not that that's not
what you're missing a tea is a
trans-esophageal echocardiogram where
essentially you put an ultrasound probe
into the esophagus in order to better
visualize the heart
he had a headlock
check his pupils
who's right people's blown antisecoria
can happen when you are having bleeding
into the brain paige neurosurgery right
freaking now
the hell are you people screwed up now
us you're on call for trauma what took
you so long
who the hell are you your response time
was supposed to be 20 minutes wouldn't
have made a difference you guys had
ordered a head seat you would call me
sooner you were supposed to be here in
20 minutes not an hour and a half we had
a chance he had a freaking chance get
out of my or
what that type of blame game can happen
in a hospital setting where there's big
egos uh i mean obviously both are in the
wrong does it matter who's more wrong no
the only thing that should matter is the
patient and trying to do the best that
they could now
it's too late
the call to not get a head ct was a bad
call
we're not a
trauma center or a teaching hub you did
the best you could i mean ahead ct like
if they made a mistake with some kind of
protocol i get it because they're not a
trauma center that makes sense but not
getting a head ct is just incredible to
me like that's the first thing you would
do in a car accident of that nature
remember the mechanism of injury there
in fact there's like a canadian head ct
protocol and one of the the points is
the mechanism of injury and it's like if
it's a high-speed accident boom you get
the head ct like i still even remember
that from med school i also don't quite
understand how they were certain that he
had abdominal bleeding over like how do
they know he wasn't bleeding into his
brain versus his abdomen like it seemed
like they just guessed that because if
you're doing anything you're pan
scanning the patient you're scanning the
head you're scanning the lungs i mean
the chest and the abdomen you're doing
it all at once mr shepherd there's some
things you need to know
some things we need to discuss difficult
things
i'm a doctor you've waited the requisite
number of hours and now you can
officially declare him dead
so the icu needs a bed those must be the
papers essentially the icu wants to
clear the patient out if there's no
improvements being made and while that
is part of what goes into medical
decision making obviously when it comes
to triage but also it's in the patient's
best interest to not be further tortured
if there's no potential chance of
recovery a stop all curative
intervention
discontinue all routine monitoring
remove all the catheters drains and
tubes
and any and all treatments that might
provide comfort to the patient
terminate
all
life-sustaining measures well see that's
not exactly true when we fill out a
pulsed form we actually can put orders
in that would put a patient on comfort
care so we would put orders in to make
sure the patient is comfortable giving
them high sedation giving them pain
control mucus control cough control
hiccup control there's all sorts of
things that we need to think about for a
patient who's at the end of their lives
and we do that with our comfort care
order set when we choose to say that
aggressively treating someone causes
them more harm than actual benefit we're
not saying discontinue everything we're
discontinuing certain things that we
feel like harm the patient and we
continue certain things or begin things
that we think would benefit the patient
meaning that the goal is no longer to
make the patient live longer but to make
the patient as comfortable as possible
oh no mcdreamy's gonna die
one of the mistakes i've seen residents
make is when they are putting a patient
on comfort care and they're
discontinuing the ventilator and all
these things they forget to turn off the
alarms because remember the alarms just
notify you when a patient's crashing and
it's very discomforting for a family to
watch their loved one go peacefully but
then the alarm's going off like crazy
that the patient's dying so you got to
turn those off as well
[Music]
and they didn't turn off the alarms
[Music]
mcdreamy one of the hardest
conversations in medicine is the
end-of-life conversation and this is
supposed to happen not just with someone
who's terminally ill someone who's just
been in a car accident it's supposed to
happen with your primary care doctor so
you could have a plan because without a
plan so many things can go wrong what's
to happen what are their wishes who's
going to be the power of attorney what
do they want from their care medically
speaking and an important aspect of that
is understanding that there's never a
surefire correct answer because patients
a lot of times will ask of me as a
doctor should i do this should i take
them off life support do they have a
chance to get better a lot of times you
have to give the most accurate answer
but it's not a 100 accurate answer a lot
of folks are not comfortable with that
but the unfortunate reality is that's
life every decision cannot be a hundred
percent and ultimately it's your choice
that has to be decided upon based on the
wishes of what the patient wanted
here's the difference between real
doctors and tv doctors click here to
check that out great video i share some
epic patient stories and as always stay
happy and healthy unlike big dreamy
[Music]